n'arrive pas à percer comment on est
presque 24 heures après ces scrutins
comment analysez vous justement c score
décevant ce revers pour le chef de
l'état
bon vous avez remarqué qu'il ya
plusieurs sièges que nous avons manqué à
quelques voix je crois qu'il ya 10 ou 12
sièges à moins de 50 points donc ça veut
dire que n'ayant pas d'électeurs au
départ puisque aucun grands électeurs
ont été élus en marche nous arrivons
presque dans dix départements
supplémentaires à ce que nous avons
gagné aujourd'hui à être élu ce qui est
quand même à vous aurez vous et une pas
mauvaise performance est ce que nous
aurions pu mieux faire sans doute
certains or une contre-performance vôtre
vous avez moins d'élus aujourd'hui la
création n'est pas les seuls mais pas
les seuls il ya d'autres groupes ici
qu'un euro - le groupe l'est républicain
et le groupe centriste va progresser
mais tous les autres groupes régresse
donc on n'est pas les seuls
donc pour tout bon ça pourrait être une
défaite aujourd'hui sauf que nous n'y
avait pas de chronique de victoire
annoncée
personne ne l'a jamais dit on avait
espéré pouvoir le faire progresser nous
ne progressons pas aujourd'hui nous
stagnons nous régressons même un peu
attendons attendant la semaine prochaine
pour connaître la composition des
groupes
on verra effectivement qui nous sommes à
égalité soudan va gagner je peux
considérer que nous aurions pu me faire
mais dans le même temps je pense que
c'est une deuxième page qui s'ouvre pour
le mouvement en marche
je tends des commentaires à peu
désobligeant que je ne relèverai pas ce
que je peux dire par ailleurs c'est que
la vraie élection sénatoriale pour en
marche et leur a lieu après les
élections municipales
aujourd'hui c'est un troisième taux de
l'élection municipale 2014 2015 2016
avec les cantonales et les régionales
qui avait produit que des grands
électeurs
appartenant soit au parti socialiste
soit au party les républicains soit
centriste quelques communistes il n'y
avait pas de grands électeurs faire avec
cela il n'y avait pas de groupe au sénat
il y a deux mois il y en a aujourd'hui
il va sans doute progressé malgré tout
mais il pèsera nantis